foreign
[Music]
am I coming through are you hearing me
clearly in this
very strange voice I have suddenly
decided to do
I won't keep it
but I'm in it at the moment and it does
not seem to wish to pull away from me it
has lodged itself upon my very person
oh dear
okay that's enough of that
hey everybody hope you're all doing well
um hope you had
a good week had a good July oh my God
it's August
had a good August so far and a good July
before that
[Music]
this year
man I
sh it's it's on freaking rocket skates
this year has been ridiculous
how quickly it has been going
anyway
everybody's doing well I don't have any
particular topics planned or um
set aside for this
um
a reminder while I will do my best to
keep up with the chat
um I cannot guarantee that I will see or
respond to your comment or question if
it's not in a super chat
um you also get a heart for me of
appreciation unless you're also on the
patreon Discord but the cutoff time to
get questions in on that was the start
of the stream so there we go
International Cat Day
hmm
I'll
A Good Day to all the international cats
out there
anything
oh yeah I know I know that guy he's an
international cat yeah
ticket
what am I doing what is it with me and
voices tonight
uh doing well minus the procrastination
you hit me where I live with that one
Stephen
I feel called out
uh
pretty sure that's alcohol
I mean you can choose to believe that I
can't stop you
ah
hey there Dharma hey Caroline Miss
Wicked Wolf Adrian B Parker Louise
Michael
all sorts of folks others that I
probably missed welcome all homebody hey
good to see you sorry I can't stay I
lost two of my feral cats last week oh
I'm really sorry to hear that Reaper
my
my sympathy for that
I saw me Mayhem cool I haven't
instead of paying the writer's Jeopardy
we'll recycle questions
so
I'd kind of rather they did like
I'm assuming that's real uh Jason and if
it is like I'd rather they didn't but
that's an interesting work around
especially for a show that's been on the
air that long that's
it's inventive
I'll give them that
is jeopardy even writers Union I'm going
to have to assume that they are
um
like most TV writer it like it doesn't
have to be
um a scripted drama for the writers to
be Union writers
um you know the
the writers for
um you know late night talk shows and
for yes game shows that they s it's a
it's a television it's a network
production they still have to be Union
so yeah they they would be
do I prefer cookie dough or brownie
batter
honestly I don't I'm not a huge fan of
either but I probably go cookie dough
at that point why not just Syndicate
reruns because ultimately fewer people
will watch a rerun than a technically
new one with old questions
uh yes gray matter this is woodchuck I'm
a vermonter I support Vermont cideries
I wonder about news writers news writers
are generally journalists and no that's
not a Union Gig so that that is uh that
is a different
area of um of TV production and of TV
writing
Kudos from Miami for walking I was about
to ask heroin whether or not she stayed
because my assumption would be that she
wouldn't and I'm glad to hear she didn't
excellent
uh
which review are you unable to make
because the writers strike are you the
most gutted about
I'm not
I'm not really gutted about any of them
what's frustrating for me is that
the knowledge that I'm going to get a
video out of it is one of the things
that keeps me on schedule with watching
stuff particularly shows so like
I'm now behind on Star Trek strange new
worlds because
it's easier for me to slot it into my
day
when it's work
so finding the time to watch it when
it's not work because I'm not going to
shoot a video on it
suddenly I'm now behind and I'm having a
hard time finding the time to watch the
show that for me is the big annoyance
um
it's not a review I'd say the video that
I very much want to make
and I intend to make and I probably will
make
um
and then just not release until the
strike is over is on is another video on
nimona
talking about it specifically as an
adaptation
um that's the one that like I have a lot
of Creative Energy for that I'm probably
the most like
sort of grumpy about
um right now but
it'll wait I'll live do I have Paramount
plus yes I do
so I finally met gun Lauren and Dawn uh
endured Angels hey Mandy he finally got
an Angel episode I gave a perfect score
to are you now or have you ever been so
for folks who don't know Rowan is
watching
um Angel and did not like the first
season uh are you now or have you ever
been is generally considered to be like
kind of the turnaround episode for that
show because first season
first season hasn't shaken off the
baggage of The Buffy format yet and it's
it's trying to do something else but
while still being a little too steeped
in the way Buffy went about structuring
itself
um on an episode by episode basis so
season two is where it starts to pick up
I I personally
think every season gets better now
that's slightly controversial because a
lot of people don't like season four and
don't get me wrong especially if you
know some of the behind the scenes stuff
there's some BS that goes on in season
four I still like season four
um granted I haven't rewatched it I will
say unequivocally the fifth season is
the best season of The Show by a lot
um and has what competes
um for my favorite final episode of a
show ever in television which
annoys me to say at this point because
you know
it means pricing Whedon but look a win
is a win it's a it's a killer final
episode
I don't know if journalists have a union
at all Jesse I'm actually not too sure
about that Dharma a member for 20 months
thank you very much almost a year on HRT
zero regrets I am very delighted to hear
that
do I like French toast I don't really
like
um sweet breakfast stuff
uh French toast pancakes waffles they're
a little too rich for me for the most
part I prefer a savory breakfast uh at
this point
um
but
I I used to like French toast when I was
younger but I just I don't have the
Sweet Tooth I used to
what would you do with a million dollars
I
pay off my debts and
set the rest aside to slowly burn
through
I don't have anything exciting that I do
just night it'd just be nice to be out
from under
uh certain debt pressures is all
season four was this helpful Charisma
Carpenter yes yes it was
my neighbor has put some kids books they
don't want on their lawn for people to
take I see that a lot I picked up Disney
Cinderella snowing Little Mermaid for my
nieces uh I think it's still okay to
expose little girl to these stories
given their problematic element elements
I mean sexism wise I
so it
I'm gonna make a broad statement when it
comes to stuff like that when it comes
to you know
the the the problems with um you know
like the the pris
I can try to just started to combine
words princess being rescued it started
to come out as Presque
the brisk you plot
um there are some inherent
um problems with that
however I don't think it's automatically
harmful to have that mixed in with a
child's story and media diet so long as
it is not making up the bulk or the
exclusive part of it I mean the thing is
while I'm not saying you should give any
given instance a pass either then or now
but a big part of the reason why there
was such a massive critique that started
to happen over time of you know Disney's
version of these
um of these stories and their projected
version of femininity that they put out
there was because it was pop culturally
dominant and when something takes up
that much space then the problems with
it amplify so taking that nothing is
perfect having those in the mix I don't
think is inherently a problem
uh is Labyrinth worth watching uh
Labyrinth is my favorite
[Music]
um
Jim Henson fell
I love Labyrinth Labyrinth is one of my
10 out of 10 don't change a word of it
perfect movies
so now that is me I also have Nostalgia
for it keep that in mind I grew up on
the thing
um but I love Labyrinth absolutely adore
there's an old video if you don't mind
seeing me in the flat cap there's an old
video on here where I talk about that I
don't know if there's spoilers in it
though
I don't know
I generally don't re-watch uh too much
of my stuff from that long ago
I have a colonoscopy next Tuesday
well may go as smoothly as possible
love cream of wheat or oatmeal done
Savory Style with milk cheddar cheese
spinach and an egg cracked in it
wholesome and good if you want a Savory
brekkie recipe see when I do oatmeal I
do like some Sweetness in there but I
like it with a mix of other things see I
like
I like
what starts out as plain oatmeal
and I like raisins in it and I like
walnuts in it but then I want maple
syrup in it I don't mean I want maple
oatmeal I mean I want regular oatmeal
that I can put real maple syrup in so
you know as long as the suite isn't
pulling the entire weight of the thing I
can still get some sweetness out of that
I can still get some enjoyments out of
sweetness geek filter thank you very
much for the Super Chat not a million
dollars but here's point zero zero one
percent towards that goal
appreciated
ah
you win five million dollars in an
aliens land and say they're gonna blow
up the Earth in three days what are you
gonna do with the money nothing
what's the point
I know you're trying to press me to come
up with more entertaining answers than
the semi-fiscally responsible adult
answers I gave to a million dollar
question is Wicked Wolf but I no I would
do nothing I would be depressed for
three days then die
ah let's see
where are we
a bit annoying with myself because there
was a book about dinosaurs just didn't
occur to me to get that one because
they're girls I usually try to avoid
thinking like that look it's not your
fault
that you have those thoughts like a lot
of this stuff is ingrained it is
embedded in our brains as we are raised
and it takes a lot
to shake it off and it takes a lot of
conscious effort because a lot of it is
so baked in that it's subconscious don't
get mad at yourself for thinking like
that
be glad that you noticed it and try and
keep it in mind going forward
you don't help anybody by beating
yourself up over
do I like Return to Oz I have not
reworked why can't I
talk
as I take another drink I wonder why
um I have not re-watched Return to Oz in
decades it's been a long time
so I
to my memory it's fine
I don't know
I have a labyrinth tattoo sleeve oh
there's plenty of stuff in there to uh
to go off of so yeah there's definitely
a basis to do that I remember the moment
from Labyrinth that you singled out as
brilliant pump or a tree no good can't
hear you yeah I love it
I absolutely love that moment it just
shows the absolute Artistry and how much
you have to think about as a performer
to put in it's oh it's phenomenal
make hot chocolate with maple syrup
that's my secret weapon people love it I
actually prefer
um mint Schnapps and my hot chocolate
now
um
if you want to do some pleasant adding
uh
this is gonna sound weird but a little
bit of maple syrup in a glass of Jack
Daniels
actually quite nice my mother taught me
that one
uh hey Vera any plans to try Baldur's
Gate three I don't really like
point-and-click navigation but Baldur's
Gate in my opinion overcomes that down
for me and me and me Circle uh are
really enjoying it well uh Tara first of
all thank you for the Super Chat
um I probably not immediately because
I'm assuming it's at full price in
probably 60 but what is that selling for
research
this is the sound of self-education
yeah that's a 60 game uh I'm not gonna
pay sixty dollars for it
I'm I'm not against trying it I might
even enjoy it I am paying 60 bucks for
it
so no ever had a Savory porridge not to
my memory
I might have if I have it has it didn't
stand out
uh I think there's a question I'm
supposed to ask you but I can't remember
it until after the stream ends ain't
that always the way of it uh Black cover
have you ever done a rank of non-canon
doctors like Peter Cushing or Rowan
Atkinson I haven't the thing is there
aren't unless I were to include like the
[Music]
um
oh crap what's the name the
[Music]
um
shoot
ah words
Unbound that's what it was unless I
include the Unbound doctors uh from Big
finish there aren't that many to do
I mean like
if I could I guess I could include every
joke regeneration from Crystal the Fatal
death but that'll be kind of odd and
token and then after what is what it's
Peter Cushing and it's Richard E Grant
like there isn't a lot to go on
um that said I do plan to eventually
watch the other Peter Cushing uh Doctor
Who movie which I haven't yet and to
eventually
um re-watch because I have seen it
before scream of the chalka and do
something on that
um
that might be uh something to do during
the strike
where are we
[Music]
I had maple syrup to mine pancakes also
Jack Daniels has Maples has a maple
syrup line I think not the same
not this it's never the same it's it's
the same thing though like so when I was
a kid
I used to have Cheerios and I would put
honey on them like fresh honey
and I kids asked me why don't you just
eat Honey Nut Cheerios
I tried hunting out churros Cheerios and
it's not the same like it's not the same
thing at all so
does stuff like Labyrinth The
Neverending Story ever make you wonder
what the 1980s Lords of the Ring would
have been like
uh
no not really because
unless the thing is unless it was going
for Whimsy most 1980s fantasy at least
live action fantasy wasn't that good
um I know a lot of folks are really
nostalgic for a lot of it I think
Labyrinth and
um never-ending story get away with it
for being highly Whimsical Lord of the
Rings has Whimsical bits but unless
you're gonna make a big to do out of Tom
Bombadil Whimsy is that
uh the main Takeaway on that one The
Hobbit a bit more so
probably would be why in the 80s at
least trying to adapt Tolkien The Hobbit
would have adapted better that said we
already had an excellent Hobbit
adaptation from ranking and bass despite
it the fact that everyone seems to
prefer to pretend that didn't happen the
Philistines
ah have you ever played or heard of the
game Steam World Heist it's not one of
the types that you say make you nauseous
it's pretty fun I have not heard of that
I played steamworld dig two so I don't
know if that's like
part of the same franchise
but um
no I haven't heard of that one when I
heard Rowan Atkinson was going to be in
Wonka I honestly thought he was going to
be playing an elder version of Wonka and
Flash forwards can you see it
sure I guess
I didn't remember noticing him in the
trailer
so I don't know who he's playing in that
John vinyls thank you very much for the
Super Chat just finished all of Sheeran
the Princess of Power and I really loved
it also I think you'd really love the
new show Haley's on it I have
never heard of that
I am not familiar I'm glad you enjoyed
it
though I love Shira I would love to
re-watch that sometime but again time
anyway
have I seen good Omens too
I have not yet and if I had I would be
keeping my opinion to myself I'm not
doing review material in solidarity with
the strike at this time
uh
so how do I get rid of a sweet tooth I
don't know uh Alyssa just happened to me
with age
so
I don't know
Conan the Barbarian I mean Conan the
Barbarian works but its fantasy elements
are incredibly thin on the ground
like there's like
two
like actual fantasy scenes in that thing
there's not much
okay uh Gendron you have repeatedly put
in this
I don't know if it's actual Latin or
mock Latin or what it is and I'm sure
it's something
I'm sure that it's something that you're
trying to either get me or the rest of
the chat to say I don't know what it is
don't know whether I should be concerned
okay
uh
all right never all right that's fine
that is a that's perfectly serviceable
as you were
have I seen the righteous gemstones nope
it's part of the same world games it's
also got music from Steam Powered
Giraffe which was featured in girl
genius once oh very cool
Rowan Atkinson is playing a throwaway
character as a priest and I think it's
wasted potential as he honestly as The
Whimsy and idiosyncratic charm to play a
version of one gut yeah except it seems
very strongly like this like Timothy
chalamet is meant to specifically be the
Gene Wilder
um Wonka and I think it's best not to
have somebody try and recreate that
specifically I mean I get iffy about
um people just literally trying to
recreate an earlier actor's performance
instead of doing their own thing with it
anyway but that's me
Jabberwocky 70s not 80s but a fantasy
Odyssey from Gilliam I remember that I
remember not liking that very much
I also saw that in like middle school
but I remember not being very impressed
with it
uh steam World Heist made by the same
people as Steam world dig but three
years later it's a whole different type
of game I love the aesthetic oh maybe
I'll take a look and see what it costs
I'm a cheapskate with my games I wait
for stuff to go on sale
on the subject of The Hobbit and having
re-watched good Omens series one
Benedict Cumberbatch really gets wasted
when he's cast as giant CG monsters
ah I've gone on record with this before
Rowan I don't like his smog
and it's not even an issue of him being
wasted I don't like his performances
Smaug I just don't like it
I've gone off on that before
yeah I did notice that Miss Wicked Wolf
and I'm not sure how I feel about Hugh
Grant as the Oompa well actually let me
back up
in a vacuum Hugh Grant as an Oompa
Loompa going that small uh going as
small as he appeared in the trailer and
be like
but given that again this does appear to
be intended to be the exact same Wonka
as
um
as we saw with Gene Wilder it's a bit
dickish
to cast a uh normal
uh not I shouldn't say normal a standard
body-sized actor and CGI them into
a little person's shape
in roles that were originated by actual
little people like that's kind of messed
up actually so
not Hugh Grant's fault strictly speaking
but
smog should be clever not angry I don't
even think smog should necessarily Be
Clever smile should be smug
he should be over confident
and
it's it's long been said by people long
before me but people with actual power
don't have to raise their voice and
don't have to try and be intimidating
because they assume they just are that's
what I actually deeply love
about
um the voice performance for the dragon
in the rank and bass animated version of
The Hobbit he
is at most mildly annoyed at being woken
up
but he's not threatened
he's not angry he's a little confused
but he's just like what is this what am
I dealing with
he doesn't have to try and be scary he
knows he is
which makes it at the point when he gets
mad it matters because it's a huge shift
whereas cumberbatch's smog seems angry
the whole way through you crank it up to
11 and stay there it's the same as
staying at one
both the Gene Wilder and Johnny Depp
versions just make you want chocolate
don't they I not necessarily for me but
you know you do you
uh
the upcoming live-action Snow White is
also kind of messing that up actually
that seems like a really so I haven't
dug into that in full but like I have
seen things that have come out following
out like this the shot from the set that
everybody got up in arms about and like
a chunk of those people are not the
actors they're stand-ins now why they're
using
um standard height stand-ins I don't
know but like
I'm
let me say this I'm not trying to give
Disney the benefit of the doubt on this
but I feel like I don't understand
enough of what it is they're actually
doing to be certain that I know what I
would need to be wagging my finger at
them over if that makes sense like
don't doubt that in some way the way
they're gonna handle this is going to be
messed up
but I feel like given what mix of
information is out there I don't know
exactly what that is and so I kind of
don't have an opinion right now
excuse me
Richard Boone's greatest smile thank you
chem dog I can never remember the name
but yes Richard Boone was
fan
band
I I remember liking the Johnny Depp
version more or less except for like the
extended bit at the end adding in more
crap with his death well I didn't get
any crap with his dad like that was
frustrating because like
Burton you were supposed to get over
your daddy issues when you made big fish
that was daddy issues the movie and it
was good and that was supposed to like
Purge all this stuff and then you insert
daddy issues into Wonka out of nowhere
ah that was frustrating other than that
I largely liked it I think a lot of it
had to do with I felt it was just
well presented and
um brought in a lot of the aspects from
the book because I did read the book A
lot of the aspects from the book that
aren't there I didn't love Depp's Wonka
but I didn't hate it either at the time
I also have not rewatched it in over a
decade so no idea what I'd think now but
I remember
John vinyls
thank you very much for the super chat
if Shira makes it to Broadway
that's not a possibility is it a verily
thou shoulds played the great role of
double trouble oh okay that's that's
where you were going with that
ah so
here's the thing I actually would be
kind of interested to play it
though I say that
with the acknowledgment that I didn't
super love Double Trouble in the show
but that wasn't an issue with the
character as written I didn't love the
performance and that's
for nitpicky personal reasons there's
nothing actually wrong with it it's just
a personal tasting it didn't
quite land right with me
although I have to wonder I if that is
the case actually it might be
if that is one of those cases of I'm
really nitpicky about it because it's a
part I kind of want to play which is how
I get
um
with
uh things like puck or the Corinthian or
desire from Sandman
um because I really want to play those
parts so I get really picky about people
who do get to play them that actually
that might be a factor
uh would I want to play Colombia in a
performance of Rocky Horror Picture Show
no give me Riff Raff or give me Frank
I would take Brad before I take Colombia
because actually I think that could be a
lot of fun to be that win bag
uh
hi
I'm Brad Majors [__]
uh oh yes thank you carowind so
um I am gonna check the Discord early
today because last few times the amount
of time I had to spend answering the
Discord questions took us to the very
end of the stream I'm gonna do that now
so hopefully I can be done with the
Discord questions and then I can come
back and have some more time with you
folks without having to extend the
stream
um for longer than I intended to
um
so reminder Council Geeks Discord is a
patreon perk so if you support Council
geeks on patreon you get access to the
Discord it's a good deal anyway I'm
gonna hop over there real quick and then
I'll be back so answering the questions
that I have there there are a fair bit
here we go
um can you think of any other characters
in any show who uh evolved to become as
complex as Londo and jakar from Babylon
5. asking as I remember assuming that
seeing uh early episodes from season one
in the 90s that they would simply be
semi-comedic background characters I
could not have been more wrong and yes I
uh would use the Shakespearean cliche so
uh the first the the main one off the
top of my head and Rowan this is
something for you to watch out for would
be Wesley Windham price introduced in
the third season of Buffy as a purely
comedic borderline bumbling character
brought into Angels still very much in
that vein and changes a lot over the
course of that show in a really
fascinating way I think he's got one of
my favorite
um sort of long-term character Journeys
uh in television I actually like him a
lot
take the outcome of the Spacey trial and
now approaching his work I still intend
to avoid his work because the thing is
so
it's not an exoneration it's not not
really because so much of the stuff that
Spacey was accused of was outside of the
statute of limitations
so there's a whole lot of it that he was
never going to be prosecuted for
and just the amount of people who came
forward the number of people with
verified stories and friends of theirs
who say they told me that at the time
that that happened I don't want to see
his face
that's not me saying that
because of my feeling he should never
get work again
but I don't want to see his face and I
will not be changing my Approach
um just like I won't be indulging in
Bill Cosby just because he was led out
of jail before his sentence was up
rightfully I will point out because the
prosecutor in his case did genuinely do
something
that was wrong that was fundamentally
wrong and because the case hinged on it
they were right to let him out not
because he didn't do it
but because the prosecutor actually did
something that is deeply unethical and
not okay so anyways that was diverting
less heavy strawberries or raspberries
raspberries I do like strawberries but I
prefer raspberries
um cookies cake or pie picnic or dinner
and a show
I feel like these are a series of
questions to try and figure out how to
ask me on a date and what to offer
pie and dinner in a show how do we seize
the means of production given the
current state of affairs I am just an
angry anti-capitalist I do not have that
much of a plan I am not the person to
give you the tools to seize the means of
production I am however here to cheer
you on and join you in the fight once we
actually get the ball rolling properly
do you like squishy fidget toys I
actually tend to favor more solid stuff
I occasionally it shows up on screen I
fidget with this a lot
which is you know just kind of a little
chain link
choker I'll mess around with Squishy
stuff sometimes like I've got this thing
and that's kind of squishy and bendy and
I'll mess with that sometimes but I like
they're okay I kind of prefer more
something a little more solid uh do you
think there is more story potential to
be had in the word of the Mona or should
we leave it alone and let it stand as is
my gut instinct is to leave it alone uh
the only way that I would not be
incredibly apprehensive about the
possibility of any SQL spin-off Etc
would be if Nate Stevenson was directly
involved in crafting that story
because if he's not then I don't want it
um and
like the the story that was told which
is quite a bit different from the
original in terms of the plot but like
the heart of that story was told it was
told beautifully
my gut instinct is leave it alone
have you heard of the band Steam Powered
Giraffe if not they are slightly
steampunk aesthetic Trio of performers
who have full faces of face paint detail
costumes robotic movements to be in
character as automatons from 1896 as
they perform in the music they have a
lot of lore and their music is good I am
somewhat familiar with actually uh we
can thank carowind for introducing me to
some of uh the band songs I'm not super
familiar with too much of it I like what
I've heard
uh band lore is not a thing for me like
I know and it that's not even to mock
the idea I actually think it's kind of
cool that some bands like have all this
lore and this narrative behind them you
know bands like the gorillas or even
kiss with a with very Bare Bones absurd
um characters that the various people
play like I do think band lore is kind
of cool I just don't engage with it I
don't have the attention span for it I'm
like I'm here for the music but
um I like what I've heard which isn't a
lot but I haven't liked it
okay moving on so my trip to the doctor
to get anxiety treatment went well but
there was one really awkward thing about
it the doctor had such a thick for an
accent I was finding it hard to
understand what he was saying I thought
I really don't want to be racially
insensitive by mentioning his accent in
this but but this is medical advice so I
really need to understand it properly
luckily he saw my confusion though it
was actually because the advice uh the
thought it was actually because the
advice was complicated and wrote it down
how would you handle having to deal with
a doctor you can't understand because
they have a thick
accent
um I don't know I've never been in that
situation I think asking for written
instructions probably would have been my
go-to request
so
I mean obviously you need good
information so you need to understand
what it is you're being told so I think
asking for something either printed out
or written down I think is probably the
best way to deal with that
why do you think being a prominent Turf
seems to consume people's lives in a way
other bigotries don't like glinner got
so obsessed with it his wife left him I
feel like other kinds of biggest while
still being terrible people are at least
capable of uh having other interests and
relationships um
here's my theory on that
most other bigotries that are prominent
such as religiously founded bigotry
racism big one misogyny uh etc etc uh
ableism
a lot of those
are baked into society to one one degree
or another
we live in a white supremacist Society
well I say we uh Americans absolutely
Europeans uh to a degree as well live in
a in a white supremacist patriarchal
society that's the society that we exist
in we just do and so a lot of the
bigotries that underpin that are just
built into the fabric of our lives so in
other words it's possible to be very
much invested in those
um misconceptions and those way and
those skewed ways of viewing the world
but it's just your normal
it it doesn't become something you have
to commit yourself to because it's just
kind of there
honestly it's active work
to fight against that stuff because as I
said it's baked into the system
transphobia isn't as much actually you
look historically at coverage of trans
people a lot of it had a lot of
misunderstanding and ignorance but there
wasn't a lot of hate behind it there was
just confusion you can find praising
even sometimes badly worded but often
largely positive articles news pieces
daytime talk show you know whatever
various things about trans people that
are for the most part positive dating
back to the freaking 50s
this level of hate is new and it's not
ingrained and baked into our society as
much so whereas
people who engage in racism misogyny
um certain religious things ableism fat
phobia Etc you kind of have to go out of
your way to stop doing that and you can
just dwell in the in the nonsense
with transphobia you have to kind of go
out of your way to do it and once you've
started going out of your way to do
something you are going to be more
committed to it you've put the effort
into it now it's going to eat up more of
your life
that's my working Theory at least
so you know I was telling you about the
contest Cartoon Network ran in the 90s
where they turned an audio recording and
kids sent in into an episode of Dexter's
Lab you pointed out a lot of the time
those content those contests didn't pay
the winner because they viewed getting
to excuse me have a thing you made on TV
as reward enough would you agree that
this speaks to the pervasive toxic idea
that getting to work in the
entertainment industry is like a
wonderful privilege not a labor you
should expect Fair compensation for like
I think it's a big part of the way
Studios think they can get away
retreating the actors and writers like
crap well I mean it's not just the
entertainment industry Society is a
whole by and large
belittles the importance of artistic
medium basically
any activity
that a person would engage in even if
they weren't being paid
but is trying to make a living off of
tends to they they tend to get looked
down their nose so this goes for
painters sculptors authors poets actors
Restless creatives who have a passion
and want to do this thing and if they
couldn't do it for pay they would be
doing some form of it for no pay because
there's something that drives them
but when you have someone who's
passionate about something makes it much
easier to take advantage of them because
you'd be like oh
you just really want to do this thing
here's some crumbs
keep doing that
whereas you get people
um in jobs that are not something they'd
be doing on their own and you kind of
have to pay them a livable wage in
theory that used to be the case at any
rate that has of course been eroded over
time with the Staggering of minimum wage
and other things but that's kind of a
separate issue that's not built into the
nature of you know work that is nobody's
passion you know nobody's passionate
about data entry but you do it
um and theoretically you get paid a
liberal wage on it or you should or you
used to but in any case yeah anybody who
has a passion for something passion is
very easy to exploit uh and from a very
young age
it's yeah it's a thing people do
uh any updates on your audiobook I am
getting back into editing that
um I am making it a mission to work on
it at least an hour a day
um during my work week
I still don't have any I'd so like let
me put it this way
if
if I can get a chapter done per week
which is ambitious but not unrealistic
we'd still be looking at it being ready
next year not this one
that's just where it's at
what's my comfort TV uh most of my
comfort film or TV show Etc I I honestly
kind of don't know anymore
because since this is my job
and pretty much anything I watch or take
in I expect to get some form of content
out of be it a review a reaction or it's
going to show up on a list somewhere or
whatever
um I don't really watch stuff for
Comfort anymore if I'm sitting down to
watch something the vast majority of the
time it's something that either is
already inherently work or I'm going to
turn it into work
I don't have
I don't have the free time to just watch
stuff for comfort
anymore that's something I'm trying to
work on I'm trying to build free time
into my life again I'm failing at it
badly but I'm trying what am I playing
on switch tomorrow I don't know yet it's
either going to be cozy Grove or potion
craft it'll be one of the two so we're
going laid back uh on tomorrow's twitch
stream but I don't know yet
this is a random question but what is
your thought process between deciding
which thumbnail to use for a video for
example
say say you've decided you're going to
appear on a thumbnail do you try to make
a facial expression that represents your
thoughts on the topic being discuss
disgust
the topic being discussed or do you try
to look your best as if you're going for
a photo shoot well the first thing is
um most of the thumbnail decisions are
made by Joel my thumbnail guy
um because I don't make my own
thumbnails uh I used to and they weren't
good
um Joel makes them now and they're much
better I don't appear in them very often
um
and at this point the only about the
only ones that I appear in consistently
um well this is main Channel I'll talk
about the break room in a second about
the only ones I appear in consistently
are reviews for Doctor Who and that's
kind of just traditional where like my
face is often shown in those so like
it's just kind of a branding thing at
this point
um not the take two but in the um
you know in the first run reviews that's
been the case uh every now and then my
face will show up and again a lot of it
a lot of it has to do with precedent
more than anything else is this the kind
of thing where I've shown my face and
usually I will want something that will
reflect my opinion somewhat now when it
comes to say the break room of Geeks
where the thumbnail is just a is just a
still from somewhere in the video and
I'll try and find something that
basically just works
it may or may not be super reflective of
my opinion sometimes I'll actually
deliberately play with that and like
have a face that's like I don't know
about this but I actually kind of like
it and it was just one bit that I was
talking about the thing so like just a
mess with people but by and large I'll
try and find a moment to use as the
thumbnail that is more or less
representative
why do you think no one's really tried
the whole interactive movie thing since
Black Mirror did it is it because of a
fundamental flaw with the idea or is it
more to do with the big Studio deeming
it too riskier time consuming to produce
I think it's both the thing is it's a
gimmick
and it's a very high
um
uh High commitment gimmick like it's a
that vanderstatch was a ton of work it
was like eight times the amount of
writing and shooting and and editing
that a standard episode of Black Mirror
was but it didn't get eight times the
viewership so so like that was done
largely as an experiment and it probably
didn't help that the single most
predominant instance of it that happened
was also a deconstruction of the idea
so basically the first big thing that
came out that was like Hey we're gonna
we're gonna try out this choose your own
How The Story Goes thing and it's a
complete tear down and deconstruction of
the very Merit of the concept
how do you pick it up again after that
so I think I think the amount of work
that is involved in it for something
that is ultimately just a gimmick like
it
it is not a gimmick that is going to
boost your engagement
high enough for it to be worth the
amount of effort in it and I think black
mayor got away with it for basically
getting there first so far as I'm aware
and
and they also deconstructed it so it's
like
what is there to even do now
you said on your YouTube feed that you
wouldn't make a video about the Miranda
Sings video and the backlash from it
would you be comfortable summarizing
your thoughts here the summary of my
thoughts on Miranda Sings is
wow
foreign
there you go that's my summary of my
thoughts on that all right
I chat now
let me see if I can catch up
um we've got new super chats in
uh did you do do do do do do do do do do
do do do do do do do do do do do do
Super Chat Supreme
Omega
on Superman film adaptations do you feel
the iconic nature of Donna Reeve films
has unfairly overshadowed any other
potential interpretations of soups
thank you
um honestly
I don't think it has overshadowed it in
the minds of the popular imagination
nearly as much as it has intimidated the
crap out of filmmakers
I think at this point
and this is not to knock uh the uh
Christopher Reeve Superman film
especially the first one
but
other than just kind of the image of him
that
is not as nearly as ingrained in
the popular culture as say I don't know
uh Judy Garland is Dorothy
those those movies are the kinds of
thing that
haven't really re-upped their investment
into each generate each new generation
of pop culture
like something like Wizard of Oz has and
I don't know why that's my go-to example
but it's just the one that's in my head
right now
um but I I think that that was true
certainly into the 90s and I'd say that
might have even been
at the time of Superman Returns
but at this point I don't really think
it is I think people are just terrified
I think filmmakers and Studio execs are
just terrified of the comparison despite
the fact that I don't think that many
people outside of folks
my age and older
actually care that much
so
how much uh transphobia is simply not is
not simply leftover squeamishness about
homosexuality
um
actually a lot of it
the tactics currently being deployed
against trans people are basically a
remix of
um tactics that were used against gay
people particularly gay men
the underlying
um
core and Seed of the hatred is a bit
different
the methodology is the same
because if you're going to oppress
people you know if it ain't broke don't
fix it
um
but like it's it is similar in so far as
the entire lgbtqia plus spectrum is
inherently disruptive and anyone who is
super invested in the false Narrative of
the nuclear white able-bodied family
being the heart and soul of the nation
somehow
um if you are super invested in that lie
then lgbtqia plus people by their very
existence are inherently threatening to
that so like it's similar in that that
entire grouping has that same impact but
like ultimately no it's not just
leftover homophobia
it's it is it is a significant mutation
when it comes to
to bigotry
uh how do I respond if my mind if my mom
glances at the screen and says something
like lol Is that man wearing lipstick or
something she's not terribly accepting
in general
I don't know
tell her to come back to the screen I'll
address her directly and say hey Mom you
don't know me
unless you want to grab a drink and
catch up
shut up
I won't do that
I don't know
I don't know the best way to respond
because there is no generic answer to
that the best way to respond has to do
with the nature of your mother and the
nature of your relationship but I don't
know either of those things
who are the other people in the intro of
Council of Geeks I've always wondered I
have addressed this so many times there
are three other people in the logo there
is Ryan there is Liz there is Paul these
are three people who have historically
appeared on channel if you go far enough
back
um and I don't want to remove them
simply because they don't appear now to
me having them still in the logo
acknowledges the history and their
presence and their contributions to what
this has been over the years so they
stay even though I have to keep
explaining who the hell they are
um do I like s'mores yeah they're okay
they're better if you can get like uh
Andy's mint chocolate those make great
s'mores
uh are there any Yuri or otherwise queer
manga you would recommend I have not
read a great deal of manga
so I have no recommendations
started Orange is the New Black last
week it has some surprisingly good trans
and Catholic representation in it as
well as being super bingeable I watched
the first two seasons really enjoyed the
second season
never came back and based off what I've
heard from people who did keep watching
I am very satisfied with that decision
Vera the motley view story is getting
really good can't wait till next week oh
thank you
thank you crochet tiger for folks who
don't know that is a reference to the d
d uh stream that I'm on called quill and
sword the backlog of um episodes are on
YouTube if you look for quill and sort
quill Ampersand sword
um and it's on Partridge quill on Twitch
every other Thursday I have a lot of fun
with that campaign it's been and I love
playing wisp wisp is really near and
dear to my heart at this point
ah
it's hard to watch The Wizard of ozone
what happened to Judy Garland I mean
that's true of most Classic Movies you
find that you scratch beneath the
surface of
well most Classic Movies how most movies
in general you're gonna find something
that's gonna make you go oh
Supreme Omega I know you criticized 90s
Comics but we're the 2000s any better I
feel the odds is more deserving of the
Grim dark label with stuff like identity
crisis the thing is the 90s bounced me
off of reading comments on comics on a
regular basis so I don't have as good a
view
of uh the 2000s era of comics the 2000s
broke DC for sure DC went to Absolute
hell
and honestly a lot of the worst aspects
of 90s extreme
were born out by Marvel not to say DC
was immune they weren't but
Marvel seem to be infected without a lot
worse but then the 2000s rolled along
and that that wasn't just Grim dark that
was nihilistic that was hateful
you talk about stuff like identity
crisis I I honestly find that story
deplorable
and I have friends who I respect and who
I know are wonderful smart compassionate
people who really like that story and I
still love them I love them no less but
I do not get it
I do not get it at all I think that
story is
I think that story is
just atrocious
I don't think I think it is a
fascinating setup
I think it's a fascinating uh starting
premise
the answer to the mystery is not good
especially considering that once you
actually know what's going on it doesn't
actually plan out pan out very well all
of the big moments of it don't even have
anything to do with the freaking mystery
they kill multiple characters for
literally no reason literally no reason
why
there are characters who have nothing to
do with the main plot who die why
there is the depiction of mental health
which is super forked
just completely and utterly formed
and then there's the entire thing with
Dr Light
which
has nothing to do with the mystery that
was the initial hook
it's just an additional thing they
uncover
and it breaks everything and I hate it
and it is gross
and it is misogynistic
and I hate it
you are not a bad person if you like
identity crisis
just like you are not a bad person if
you like The Shining
just like you're not a bad person if you
like hell Bend
but I hate these things
I hate them
and of those three things that I
mentioned I think I probably hate
identity crisis
um
oh hang on
OBS got weird on me in my back
all right I hate identity crisis on a
similar basis by which I hate the idiots
Lantern episode of Doctor Who I find it
gross
I find it gross that that that it was
determined that these plot beats and
these story moments were deemed
acceptable
I I think it's gross
since anxiety got bad I had this toxic
relationship with my dad where where
drunkenly expressed in the middle of the
night and he tells me he's mad at it in
an ableist way because I'm autistic
ah
sounds like there is a lot to unpack and
work on their
probably like collectively
um you know within the family and I I am
not a therapist or counselor so I'm not
really
in a position as uh to offer advice on
that I can only wish you the best of
luck
have you ever listened to the bad guys I
find their uh explorations of historic
homophobia and often like they're up
fascinating I am not familiar
uh is it okay to identify you as
non-binary I think
um I don't think mother is familiar with
gender fluid I mean non-binary is not
inaccurate
the only reason I don't use the term
um generally is because when most people
hear non-binary they think a fixed sense
of gender that is between or outside of
the male and female binary system
whereas the reason I'm not binary is
sometimes I'm in there but my thing
doesn't stay put but non-binary is not
inaccurate gender fluid is a non-binary
identity so if you want to identify me
as non-binary I'm not insulted because
it's it's technically accurate it's just
a term I don't use because it tends to
conjure a more specific notion in a lot
of people's heads and it's one that the
standard thought that people get in
their mind when they hear the word is
not accurate to me so that's normally
why I don't use it but it's not
inaccurate
why do trans people seem to get more
discrimination than any other people in
the LGBT Spectrum especially from other
people on the Spectrum
there are a lot of reasons for that
Robin I will try and break that down
quickly because I know I'm running over
time
um
the first is that the reason trans
people are the big Target is because
the conservative movement the religious
right the far right the alt-right
um they have at least for the time lost
their war against homosexuality they
have not let's be clear they have not
stopped hating gay people lesbians and
bisexuals but they have had to accept a
ceasefire on that pretty much
uh ever since uh
the uh the legalization of gay marriage
in the U.S now if that ever goes away
it'll be right back to going after them
again but what they realize is that
trans people are different enough from
the sexuality spectrum that they that
they can Target them for different
reasons and that there will be some
members of the lgbtqia plus Community
who will join them in those criticisms
and go after trans people because we are
different like a non-standard gender
identity is a fairly different thing
from a non-heterosexual sexuality in
terms of the way that it manifests and
how it affects your life going forward
now the lgbtqia plus Community is still
a global Community because we have a
shared struggle but like the specifics
are different enough that certain people
within the community feel it's okay to
ostracize us and it makes it easier for
the right to single us out and come up
with
um things to say about us that don't
like let me be clear they want anything
that they say about us to Splash back
onto the rest of the queer Community but
it doesn't look like as broad a thing
because they're going after us in
specific
we are currently getting more
discriminated against because we are the
one that honestly probably through
process of elimination they landed on as
we can really hammer on this
because
collectively most societies
it took a while it took too long but
most societies eventually put their foot
down on homophobia and said hey
that's not acceptable
the foot has not been put down
on transphobia so it is acceptable
because they've lost one of their
Outlets of homophobia they are going to
go harder it's not like they're just oh
well we'll do this to the same degree we
were also doing homophobia no you were
going to do transphobia anyway now all
the energy that would have gone into
homophobia is being supercharged into
transphobia I say that is if hate is a
finite resource it's not like love it is
sadly borderline infinite but oh the
comparison makes sense anyways
yeah
all right gonna try and wrap up here
oh
I'm from the UK and trying to deal with
the many issues surrounding the NHS
gender identity card but do you think
the wpath guidelines need updating and
should be more closely followed
unfortunately Spirit born because I'm in
the US I don't know enough
about the inner workings of the NHS to
have an opinion on that I honestly don't
know because it's not a system I'm super
familiar with because it's not what I
have to deal with
um John vinyls sneaking in one more
Super Chat it is very appreciated if you
haven't seen shmikodun on Apple TV I
think you'd really enjoy that show I
really like the trailers for that I
don't have Apple TV I don't know if I'll
ever get around to it
uh
anyways I actually got new drugs in the
long run so don't worry about me well I
hope they help 255 A.D
um just know that they take a little
while to settle
um like and then to figure out your
correct dosage and whatever that's it's
a process
anyways I think that's about it we're
gonna wrap it up there
oh
hope everybody had fun the conversation
kind of went up and down it got serious
at a few points but I think for the most
part we had a good time
thank you all for joining me
um
good water
so thank you everybody
thank you for joining me I hope you have
a great rest of your day and please
remember
oh um
just a couple of things uh tomorrow
there will be my video giving my opinion
for the 10 best episodes of Doctor Who
starring the 13th Doctor Jody Whitaker
that goes up tomorrow
um I will also be streaming on Twitch
tomorrow 10 30 a.m eastern daylight time
as mentioned earlier I'll either be
playing uh cozy grow over potion craft
not sure yet it'll be one of the two
excuse me I'll be streaming again on
Friday
Saturday I'll have a video out talking
about just
the idiocy of the um
major moving in network and movie
studios and networks over focusing on
franchises
um because they're doing it again like
they've done it for a while but like
they're really stepping in it again so I
apparently need to uh need to make my
points on that again but in any case
that's what's coming up I hope that you
have a great rest of the day rest of the
week I'll be back here in two weeks and
uh please remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
McCaffrey